the United States says it has serious
concerns about the docking of a
sanctioned Russian cargo vessel at a
South African Port last year it says the
Russian ship the lady R picked up
weapons during its stop at a Cape Town
naval base in December the comments of
angered South Africa which says there's
no evidence to support the claim but
it's promised an investigation South
Africa has refused to condemn Russia's
invasion of Ukraine saying it wants to
remain neutral in the conflict well
Richard culland is from the University
of Cape Town he says president ramaphosa
has given Parliament a very muddled
explanation
well the presidency has equivocated
somewhat on the one hand president
ramaphosa told Parliament this afternoon
that he would need to look into it I
think that was an unsatisfactory answer
in the circumstances when a a major
power like the United States in the
context of the Ukrainian War makes such
a an environment with such forcefulness
as the ambassador of the United States
South Africa did this afternoon I think
it requires a clear response however on
the one hand the United States have
refused to hand over the evidence as it
were to the South African government
they say according to the presidency of
South Africa that they will only do so
to a credible Authority so that raises
the question of whether the United
States now distrust the South African
government to such an extent that it's
unwilling to give such evidence over to
them the presidency tells me that the
president of South Africa therefore had
no choice faced by on the one hand this
averman from the Americans and on the
other hand his own government saying
that they have no knowledge of this the
defense Ministry has told the presidency
they have not sold or given arms to the
Russians and therefore the president has
had to react by appointing a former
judge to look into the matter